[Music]
big mike why were you going to the gym
because it's warm
do you have any place to stay tonight
don't you dare lie to me
hello i'm maud garrett and welcome back
to another episode of rt essentials
today we are counting down the greatest
portrayals of real life people in movie
history based on what critics and fans
like you had to say on rotten tomatoes
and speaking of someone who plays a real
person on camera all the time let me
assure you it is not as easy as it looks
granted i am playing myself i'm not
really acting i'm just telling you about
classic movies but it can get a little
toasty under these lights okay
let's get on to the list
jamie foxx rey that's a b flat c7 scan
it up and triple it off the back end
yeah
yeah that's it
ray
what did i tell you about cooking in the
dark
are you trying to burn the house down
think about it marlene what do i need to
light for well you don't need to be
cooking anyway we brought you take out
from oscars jamie foxx took home the
oscar for best actor for his role as ray
charles in the 2004 film rey portraying
the legendary r b musician from the
years 1948 when he was just 17 all the
way up to 1965.
before making the film in 2002 fox had a
chance to spend some time with the real
ray charles they even played some piano
together with rey kinda testing out
jaime's skills and making him keep up
with some complicated thelonious monk
songs eventually rey stood up and said
the kids got it giving fox the
confidence he needed to pull off the
performance after that initial meeting
though the actor chose not to spend much
more time with the real ray charles he
was afraid of getting to know the 73
year old version of the man and playing
that guy instead of his younger self
possibly lots of talk about soup and
naps in that version but how cool are
naps
relax really relax
what are y'all gonna hear
how about a little neck king cole
[Music]
to focus on the younger ray fox borrowed
some tapes from the library of one of
his oldest friends iconic music producer
quincy jones fox was particularly taken
with a 1959 interview on the diner shaw
show when diner asked about his issues
with drugs rey started a bit before
answering a tick that fox picked up on
in the film
we should begin psychotherapy sessions
look uh look at the head's drinking back
i can handle this
mr charles you're not the first
celebrity junkie i've treated jackie to
get into the mindset of a blind man he
also wore prosthetic eye pieces that
rendered him sightless for 12 to 14
hours a day and studied at braille at
first the use of the prosthetics gave
him panic attacks making him feel shut
off from the world and claustrophobic
but he got used to it over time
more painful i'm sure was the fact that
his co-stars would sometimes forget that
he couldn't see and abandoned him at the
lunch table with no way to get back to
set that or it was a bit personal
joaquin phoenix walk the line
hello i'm johnny cabs
oddly enough luck in phoenix initially
met iconic country musician johnny cash
at a dinner party well before he ever
knew he'd be playing him in a movie at
one point during the evening cash
actually pulled working aside and
complimented his work in gladiator
quoting some of his favorite lines from
the evil emperor commodus
honestly that sounds like a fun party
i'm clearly not hanging out with the
right people around here
phoenix and rhys witherspoon who plays
cash's wife june in walk the line do all
of their own singing and even learned
how to play their character's signature
instruments fenix wasn't initially sure
that he wanted to do his own singing but
agreed to at least give it a try on the
insistence of the director james mangold
he worked with a vocal coach and
producer t-bone burnett with a
particular focus on mastering cash's
familiar deep baritone
you're not
[Music]
you got somebody to do that for you john
you got a wife somewhere you remember
that
what if i didn't
there's too many f's in that sense
only one actually
there's only one f in s sentence june
during an appearance on conan o'brien's
show phoenix described the process and
the vocal exercises he was asked to do
as painfully awkward and embarrassing he
remained so uncertain that he could
portray kash's voice his backing band
learned to play two versions of each
featured song one is cash's original key
and one in a higher key for work in
phoenix eventually though the actor was
able to make the adjustment and the
versions you hear in the movie are the
original songs just as johnny cash
performed them
[Applause]
again
what about that june carter isn't she a
sweetheart
phoenix was oscar nominated for his role
and walked the line but he didn't walk
away with the win he wouldn't reach the
podium until joker in 2020. the
soundtrack though which featured work in
performing cash's vocals won a grammy so
he's still working with the solid go the
grammy and the oscar at this point just
waiting on that e and the t maybe joker
gets a spin-off series and a broadway
musical
charlie is there on monster i shot him
all right
you're happy now
i'm sorry you let your phone down all
right
no now you know myself now you help me
all right the 2003 crime drama monster
was the directorial debut of future
wonder woman director patty jenkins
she'd been in contact with real serial
killer aileen wuornos in prison and
planned to use her as a consultant for
the eventual film production the night
before her 2002 execution at age 46 she
gave jenkins a personal trove of
documents containing 12 years of her
correspondence with a childhood friend
this material laid the groundwork for
what the movie would become look i'm not
gonna
look i feel sorry for you oh but if you
want a ride
you better come on see i don't need a
ride man
yeah i don't need a ride
cause i'm gonna take your car
according to jenkins charlie's theron
was always her first choice to play
wanos after seeing the devil's advocate
on late night tv and noting how far the
actress was willing to push herself to
express her character's inner turmoil
jenkins felt certain that they could
physically make just about any actor
resemble the real warners but she needed
someone who could sell audiences on the
woman's inner pain and struggle before
theron agreed to take the role kate
winslet and brittany murphy had also
pursued it in order to complete the
physical transformation theron gained
over 30 pounds wore contact lenses to
change her eye color and donned a dental
prosthetic to give her an artificial
overbite
sorry
i can't believe you're here
me neither
monster premiered at the berlin film
festival and theron picked up the silver
bear prize for best actress this was
just the first of many many awards you'd
take home for the film including the
golden globe the sag award the
independent spirit award the national
board of review and national society of
film critics award and of course the
oscar for best actress at the time roger
ebert called it one of the greatest
performances in the history of cinema
which is like the equivalent of what
like eight nine thumbs up
we only have two that's like a lot of
thumbs
ben kingsley gandhi
we will need another place set for mr
walker's driver
i will tell tara
yes it's
one way to learn that each man's labor
is as important as another's in fact
while you're doing it cleaning the
toilet seems far more important than the
law the epic 1982 film gandhi runs three
and a half hours in length and traces
the indian activist and leader's life
from his arrival as a young lawyer in
south africa in 1893 through his
assassination at age 79 in 1948. ben
kingsley who stars as mahatma gandhi in
the film was born and raised in the uk
but is actually half indian on his
father's side his birth name was krishna
banji which he changed after embarking
on a stage acting career mohandas k
gandhi attorney at law
i'm on my way to pretoria to conduct a
case for an indian trading firm didn't
you hear me
there are no colored attorneys in south
africa sir
i was called to the bar in london
and enrolled at the high court of
chancery
i am therefore an attorney when kingsley
and director richard attenborough first
discussed collaborating on the film they
watched about four hours of newsreel
footage of the real gandhi together in a
movie theater kingsley wasn't sure he
could pull off a performance of such an
iconic and world famous figure and took
a lot of convincing from attenborough
before agreeing to take the role he
later compared the project to climbing a
mountain staring up at the entire
cliffside makes it seem impossible but
you can do it if you just focus on
scaling the rocks right in front of your
face
[Music]
that was lucky
i thought you were a man of god i am but
i'm not so egotistical as to think he
plans his day around my dilemmas
kingsley prepared for the role by
reading biographies and screening even
more newsroom footage but also relied
heavily on studying still photographs
which he said helped him decide in the
moment how to position himself and use
his body he also adopted gandhi's
vegetarian diet throughout the
production losing 20 pounds in the
process and learned to spin cotton
thread on a wooden wheel as the real
gandhi would sometimes do while holding
conversations which is like the 19th
century version of being distracted on
your phone while your friend's talking
sandra bullock the blind side look
here's the deal
i don't need y'all to approve my choices
all right
but i do ask that you respect them
you have no idea what this boy's been
through and if this is going to become
some running diatribe i can find an
overpriced salad a lot closer to home
the role of leanne tuie the tennessee
mum and interior designer who along with
her husband sean took in future nfl star
michael owa had originally been
earmarked for julia roberts by 20th
century fox executives ultimately
roberts and director john lee hancock
couldn't work out the timing together
and the project went into limbo for
several months until sandra bullock came
on board what's the situation with
michael he needs to do better in school
obviously but why the big push well he's
in line for a football scholarship if he
gets his grades up
is he considering ole miss
better be
i'd love to work with him bullock was
drawn to the story as she was hoping to
make something inspirational about good
people who want to make the world better
still she had some initial concerns
about getting into leigh ends mindset
specifically doing justice to her devout
conservative christian beliefs it took
reading the michael lewis book which the
film is based on and then traveling to
memphis and getting to know the real
leanne and her family to convince her to
make the film the blind side in fact
bulk ended up staying a few days at the
tui's home and had a chance to take in
the entire neighborhood
it's mine
yes sir
what
never had one before
what a room to yourself
a bit
leanne tui for her part was already a
sandra bullock fan she immediately
thought bullock was a good match to play
her because she has a sweetness but also
a bit of an edge just watch demolition
man if you don't believe me the two
became close to the point that bullitt
consulted the real leanne extensively
during production
she'd really dig into details too not
just wanting to know how leanne felt
about certain people or specific
interactions but what she was wearing on
that day what her makeup looked like and
so on leanne said her email would
frequently blow up with new queries from
sandra bullock olig took home a number
of trophies for this performance
including the golden globe the sag and
the oscar
robert de niro raging bull
these two men who bears powerful
fighters dangerous so much so that no
other fighter will go near them and so
they fight each other three weeks apart
they've each won one and they'll
probably fight again the way it looks
now
they go to post quarters at the bell
raging bull producers erwin winkler and
robert chartoff had previously worked
with the same studio united artists on a
little boxing picture called rocky that
movie's incredible blockbuster success
had inspired a number of imitators
making films about boxers a major
up-and-coming genre in the late 1970s in
fact in 1978 when director martin
scorsese and actor robert de niro were
first workshopping raging bull it was
one of five boxing movies currently in
development alongside rocky ii the main
event the champ and matilda the last
one's about a boxing kangaroo good on
you
[Applause]
original screenwriter mardik martin
adapted the story from fighter jake
lamotta's own 1970 memoir called raging
bull my story and had even spent a few
days living with lamotta's ex-wife vicky
in florida to pick her brain about her
memories that first script included very
little about lamotta's brother joey and
featured his close friend peter savage
who had co-written the book with him as
its main supporting character it was the
suggestion of taxi driver vet paul
schroeder who did a pass over the
screenplay that they replaced savage's
character with joey as brothers would be
more compelling on screen than just
friends
[Music]
i don't have any gloves anyway we're
going to hit you with a table
who's that over there
wrap it around your hand how many times
i got to tell you
not too many more de niro plays la moda
at two periods of his life in the film
to play the boxer as a young man he went
on a strict diet and worked out every
day with the real lamotta for an entire
year at the gramercy gym on east 14th
street in new york lamotta estimated
that they boxed a total of about a
thousand rounds together to play the
older more out-of-shape la moda de niro
took a four-month break and ate his way
through some of the finest restaurants
in france going from 160 to 215 pounds
score says he became worried about the
impact on the star's body and health
after noting that his breathing became
heavier but he's alright folks he's
still going strong meeting those fockers
after all these years
forrest whittaker the last king of
scotland
you took oh my god
yeah who are you
i'm doctor nicholas galligan
i won't get medical compounding
i'm a doctor you are british
why didn't you say so it's important to
note that while ugandan president
idiomin was a very real historical
figure the movie the last king of
scotland is based on a 1998 novel by
author giles foden and is not actual
history foden actually says his book is
influenced both by the real idiom in and
shakespeare's macbeth
[Music]
to play the infamously cruel dictator
actor forest whitaker immersed himself
in the role for months prior to the
start of shooting he learned basic
swahili enough to converse with the
ugandan actors and crew members on set
plus gained about 50 pounds for the role
trained to play the accordion studied
the country's rich history and culture
and spent months in uganda meeting
amin's family members former colleagues
and other government officials he also
spoke with those who'd suffered at the
hands of a min and his brutal regime
eventually whitaker says that he spent
so much time thinking about idiom in
that he started appearing in his dreams
[Applause]
the real key to unlocking the character
for whitaker was watching a documentary
that contained his home movies alongside
his family and children
these kind of intense preparations
aren't out of character for forrest
whitaker earlier in his career when
preparing to play jazz great charlie
parker in bird he hid himself away in a
small loft for months and taught himself
to play saxophone
sax plus accordion we're getting pretty
close to a one-man band here i mean
thick and master playing the symbols
with his knees i think we really got
something here
rami malik bohemian rhapsody
crazy cross-dressing freddy freddy the
freak freddie the [ __ ]
i'm tired of touring aren't you album
tour album tour ramy malik had always
been a queen fan and when he was offered
the role of the band's front man freddie
mercury in bohemian rhapsody he said he
felt immediately in his gut that he had
to take the part he later described it
as a gun to the head moment when he had
to spontaneously make a gut-check
life-changing decision the surviving
members of the band were all
co-producers on the film so the actor
had a chance to spend time with them and
pick their brain about their famous lead
singer
he recalls one evening he and brian may
were eating dinner in london and they
bumped into king's front man ray davies
and the two rock legends regaled him
with stories about freddy and the
lasting impression that he made on
people
imagine
thousands of people
doing this in new zealand
what's the lyric
the film's memorable live aid sequence
was the very first thing to be shot on
day one of production to prepare malik
spent hours each day with a movement
teacher to copy mercury's own actions
while making them seem spontaneous and
in the moment
as for the actual singing the film
features an amalgamation of freddie
mercury and rami malek's voices often
scenes lead in with malik's voice and
then pick up mercury's vocals along the
way higher
jesus how many more galileos do you want
one more
one more
[Applause]
dental technician chris lyons designed
the infamous false teeth malek wears
throughout the film to capture mercury's
signature look he's a working dentist in
the uk but also has a side business
called fangs fx it does fake chief for
movies
daniel day lewis lincoln why tarnish
your invaluable luster with a battle in
the house it's a rat's nest in there
it's the same gang of talentless hicks
and hacks who rejected the amendment ten
months ago we'll lose
i like how jazz is now good ol abe
lincoln has been portrayed many many
times in american films from dw
griffith's 1930 biopic to john ford's
young mr lincoln to that one scene in
villain ted's excellent adventure where
he tells the graduating class of san
dimas high school to party on dudes day
lewis spent a year preparing to play the
former president he started by reading
both team of rivals and a biography of
lincoln by carl sandberg along with many
selection of lincoln's own writings
he also studied photographs of honest
abe taken towards the end of his life by
alexander gardner
i might not even want to be a lawyer
it's a sturdy profession
and a useful one yes and i want to be
useful but now
not afterwards i'm wearing them things
mr sleeve they never fit right even
though there are no actual lincoln audio
recordings in existence we typically
think of the man as having a very deep
baritone probably because of his fame as
an orator but day lewis found some
research indicating that he actually had
a higher pitched voice in reality and
also read studies that indicated that
higher pitched voices actually carry
better in large crowds he said coming up
with lincoln's voice and being able to
hear it was what unlocked the entire
role for him
things which are equal to the same thing
are equal to each other
that's a rule of mathematical reasoning
it's true because it works
has done and always will do most actors
who play lincoln have to wear lifts in
their shoes in order to achieve his
famously imposing physical presence but
daniel day lewis himself stands pretty
close to the real man's six foot four
frame doris kern's good win took him on
a tour of lincoln's home and law offices
in springfield illinois and noticed that
day lewis had to stoop down to
accommodate the low ceilings just as the
real abraham lincoln did
marion kotia lavigne rose
[Music]
have you decided
please
[Music]
filmmaker olivier de haan was convinced
that marion kotia was the only choice to
play famed french singer edith piaf
before he'd ever even met the actress he
saw a photograph of her and felt that
her eyes expressed the same sadness as
pf's then wrote the entire script with
her in mind to play the lead role what a
compliment your eyes are sad
[Music]
what do you know the filmmaker was right
all along kotiya won the best actress
oscar for her turn as pf in la vie en
rose taking home the first ever academy
award for a french language performance
she also won the golden globe and the
praise of famed british theatre director
trevor nunn who called this one of the
greatest performances in the history of
film
spent five hours a day in makeup and
also shaved down her eyebrows and
hairline in order to mimic piaf's
distinctive look she felt certain during
production that it was causing her
friends and family to treat her
differently
and though she's responsible for 100 of
the acting that's not kotya's voice that
you're hearing perform pf's classic
songs this was in part because she was
wearing a mouth prosthetic which
radically impacted her ability to sing
and the quality of her vocals kotia got
so deep into the role that she later
told the guardian she had trouble saying
goodbye to piaf after filming was
completed it took her eight months to
feel entirely free of the character and
that was only after she traveled the
world took part in a number of shamanic
ceremonies and even had this is true an
exorcism performed to release pr spirit
and he thought acting was just playing
pretend and hanging out in a trailer all
day come on well there they are folks
among the greatest performances of all
time featuring some of those rare
occasions where beloved celebrities
actually disappear and in their place
infamous or iconic figures from the past
re-emerge keep it here on rotten
tomatoes for lots more fun and
fast-paced glimpses into our shared
cinematic legacy and now if you'll
excuse me i've got to get some of these
prosthetics off it is really draining to
play a real person even if it is myself
that's what i've learnt today
[Music]
[Music]